okay all right
try to be a little bit louder than that
welcome to the workshop we are delighted
all right thanks everyone for showing up
what is what is maybe a little bit early
on the west coast so I'm gonna talk
about adaptive data analysis in my talk
actually not about differential privacy
animal will do some of that and probably
for you know a little bit less than half
the audience you'll know a lot about
what I'm going to say but hopefully this
is a friendly introduction to the kinds
of problems that we've been studying in
the computer science community for the
last few years to the other half of the
audience so maybe like a good sort of
example to begin with is to think about
the imagenet competition which was
particularly interesting and it's in its
2015 iteration so this is a sort of
classification competition where you've
got a bunch of images a lot of them 1.5
million in the training set and you want
to categorize them into a bunch of sort
of pretty finely defined categories and
the way the competition was run is that
these training images were made
available to everyone but competitors
were going to be scored on on a
validation set of about a hundred
thousand images and there was you could
check the performance of your model on
this validation set but they were sort
of you know a little bit concerned that
this wasn't a safe thing to do so they
they added a limitation that you could
only check your performance twice per
week so so in the 2015 iteration you
know there was this exciting
announcement in March by Baidu
they announced that they'd achieved a
record accuracy you know beating those
those Schmucks at Google they posted a
paper about this the the team lead said
that you know they were now leading the
race and computer intelligence they had
great power in there
much greater than their competitors this
was the the great power they had but it
quickly sort of came out that they had
cheated so how had they cheated it
turned out that they circumvented this
rule that you could only test two models
per week instead they'd registered 30
fake accounts that they could check a
lot of models per week and so this was
discovered they were banned from the
competition for a year the the paper was
withdrawn and the guy who said this was
fired but sort of what the basic
question that I want to talk about in
this hour is you know okay why was this
cheating like why did being able to
validate your model over and over help
and what is the sort of thing that we
might imagine doing as algorithm
designers to prevent that so you know
the the most basic problem with
validating you know a lot of different
hypotheses is what's what's known as the
multiple comparisons problem and is you
know the problem of uniform convergence
in in machine learning
let me introduce it to just in the you
know in the framework of validating you
know like the performance of machine
learning models although of course it's
more general so suppose we've got some
classifier that Maps you know images to
labels we've got some data set let's
assume that it consists of n entries
that are drawn iid from some fixed but
unknown distribution and the thing we
want to know is the sort of performance
of our classifier so maybe we've got
some loss function that you know just
measures whether we've gotten the
correct label or not you have lost one
if you get the incorrect label although
again we could talk about other loss
functions and the thing that you're
interested in is the true loss of this
classifier on the distribution by which
I mean you know the expected value of
the loss function when I draw a new
example from the distribution and then
try to classify it like the probability
that I get the error wrong now this
quantity is defined with respect to the
distribution which I don't have direct
access to and so the thing that we can
actually estimate is not the true
but rather the empirical laws right so I
can I can look at my data set and I can
look at on average like what is the
performance of my classifier on my data
set so I can estimate this but I want to
know this now fortunately you know it's
it's not too hard to to relate these
things you know if things inequality
allows us to basically put confidence
intervals around our empirical estimates
so you know I can say that you know even
with not too much data I've got you know
pretty good estimates for what the true
loss is in fact with probability one
minus Delta the difference between my
empirical estimate of the loss and the
true loss is something that sort of
going to zero at on the order of sort of
1 over the square root of the number of
data points I've got that's pretty good
ok so that's not the multiple
comparisons problem this is sort of
estimating a single you know statistic
the multiple comparisons problem is what
happens when I've got more than one
statistic suppose I've got K different
classifiers so I you know if I tried to
just use exactly the same bound from the
last slide to bound not just my you know
empirical loss for one of these
classifiers but my sort of loss for the
least accurate of these classifiers and
the reason I might want to do that is if
for example I'm gonna look at all of my
classifiers and report only the one that
is most accurate then I might sort of
need to have confidence intervals around
the accuracy of all of them
simultaneously you know just because
there's more than one of them the the
bound from the previous slide won't be
valid anymore so to be conservative what
we can do is we can just ask for a
uniform convergence we can ask first
confidence intervals that simultaneously
if with probability 1 minus Delta
simultaneously hold for every model in
this class ok so that we can just apply
the Hough tting inequality together with
a Union bound or what you might call a
bonferroni correction if you're a
statistician and you know basically our
our sort of
confidence parameter that was previously
Delta will now just set it to be Delta
over K and and now we have sort of
simultaneous confidence intervals that
hold for every classifier every model in
our class where you know all I've paid
is in the logarithm I've got sort of a
log K where before I had a a constant up
here so this is actually still pretty
good like when n is large right because
our you know our error bound goes to
zero at our root at a rate of 1 over
square root of n but instead of growing
with K only logarithmically and K this
is a very mild correction right in fact
when you look at what Baidu did they
only submitted roughly 200 classifiers
so K wasn't that big the size of the
validation set was pretty big n was a
hundred thousand so actually you know it
looks like you can apply sort of
simultaneous 95% confidence intervals
around all of the models they submitted
that have sort of whiff that is actually
small enough to confirm their
improvement over Google's model but but
there's a there's a problem here
like you know in this in this sort of
exercise we assumed that all of these
classifiers were fixed up front okay and
we took a Union bound over them but you
know if you're sequentially submitting
these models to be verified that's not
the case that you have what we're going
to call adaptivity in that you can
choose the next model to submit as a
function of the answers you got from
your previous checks and so you know
this this sort of simultaneous
confidence interval bound that we can
just get just by applying a huffing
inequality and a Union bound it no
longer works it's not correct so let's
think about what can go wrong so here's
sort of a simple thing we might do I
want to think about binary data just for
this example so you know think about our
data as having D boolean features every
feature can be true or false our label
is also binary and we're just going to
think about the following you know
learning procedure that's just going to
operate through the kind of
model validation interface that Baidu
had available to them okay so we're
gonna do something very reasonable for
every feature we're just going to figure
out what is the error of the simple
classifier that just predicts that the
label is equal to the IFT feature so
we're just checking the correlation
between the ayth feature and the label
and if our empirical loss is less than
50% so if it looks like our feature is
sort of weakly correlated with the label
we'll remember that
we'll set this variable to 1 otherwise
if it looks like our our feature is
weakly anti-correlated with the label
we'll remember that as well okay we'll
sit this feature equal to negative 1 and
our final classifier will just be sort
of this linear threshold function which
is just a majority vote we're going to
look at a new example we'll see if it
has more variables that are that we've
decided are correlated with the label
than it has but our anti-correlated if
so we'll decide the labels one otherwise
we'll decide the labels minus one okay
this thing doesn't ask that many
questions by the way it validates D plus
one models in total one for every
feature and then the final one so I
haven't told you what the data
distribution is but before I do that let
me just show you oh yes plus one yeah
okay so let's like see what happens when
we run this keeping in mind that I
haven't yet told you what the data
distribution looks like so this is just
a plot of the sort of reported final
accuracy of the last classifier we
submitted where I'm just varying on the
illegible x-axis the number of features
in my data goes from 1 to 50,000 and the
confidence intervals I'm plotting here
are just to the sort of bonferroni
corrected confidence intervals that you
would get by naively applying you know
like a Union bound to the D plus 1 model
so you've submitted ok so what you can
see is that yes especially as the number
of features grows we're getting a more
and more accurate classifier and our
confidence intervals are telling us that
this is a real phenomenon right like
we're like we're like definitely doing
better than
50 percent error okay but you know what
I didn't tell you is that in this plots
actually the data and the labels are
entirely uncorrelated with one another
they're all uniformly distributed with
no relationship to one another
so all classifiers have error you know
exactly 50% and the bonferroni
correction is clearly sort of
catastrophic Lee failing here like we're
not only are we sort of appearing to get
accuracy if it's much higher than 50%
the the confidence intervals are
misleading us into thinking that it's
statistically significant okay so I want
to think about first like why that's
happening what the sort of bun for any
correction is failing to take into
account and then you know what we could
do to to fix it okay so okay what I'm
drawing here is what in a nice paper of
Gelman and Loken they called the garden
of the forking paths'
but you know okay what is that garden
you know you can draw a sort of in our
case since our procedure was very simply
specified you know like a decision tree
of what our learning procedure would
have done in every eventualities it's
checking the first feature it's seeing
whether it's correlated with the label
or not and it's remembering that so
think about that as the left or the
right branch when checking the second
feature it's deciding whether it was
correlated the label or not it's
remembering that that's taking the left
or the right branch at the second level
okay and by the time it's gotten down to
the the beliefs it's asked a question
like this for each of the D features it
decides on some classifier okay and now
there's like two to the D classifiers
that it could have come up with one for
each choice of whether the label was
correlated or not okay now a particular
run of this algorithm just take some
particular path down this tree it asks
you know D plus one questions in total
but of course you know it could have
taken any other path and in this case
they were all equally likely okay so
like the the problem the thing that like
misled us when we were trying to simply
apply this bond for any correction is we
applied it to the D plus one questions
we actually asked the particular path we
took down the tree but
like there were a vastly larger number
of models that we could have checked
there were two to the D and if we wanted
to sort of be safe what we would have
had to do was apply the bun for any
correction to all of those - all of the
- to the D models that we might have
asked ok so this is what I think Gelman
and Logan called the sort of implicit
multiple comparisons problem you have to
be careful to correct for not just the
questions you actually asked but all of
the questions you might have asked had
the answers come out differently okay
and like in this case right so
conservatively you have to correct for
all of those in this case it seems like
you really do have to in the sense that
you know like you'd have to plug in a
number of models into the sort of bond
for any correction that was equal to 2
to the D basically before these
confidence intervals became wide enough
to correctly account for the true 50%
error that all of these models have
okay so okay you could imagine doing
that but it's got some issues
so first the corrections are just like
giant like in this case you know like
you'd have to take a Union bound over to
to the D models your confidence
intervals would become like trivial in
this case for good reason because you're
not really learning anything so the
problem is that apptivity
you know first like blows blows up the
implicit multiple comparisons problem by
an exponential factor the other thing is
you know like it at least for this
procedure we could have implicitly done
it like if we if we know a very precise
and simple description of the analysis
procedure that we're doing you know then
we have you know like a map of the
garden we can Union bound over all of
the leaves but in general that's an
unusual case right like whenever the
decision procedure itself is not as
complicated or not precisely specified
for example if there's a human being in
the loop making decisions then we're not
we're not even be able to draw this tree
right we're not gonna have a map of
Gelman on Logan's Garden of the forking
paths and we'd like to either write two
different issues the first is even if we
have the map
you know just correcting for everything
every model we might have arrived at is
just sort of expensive but the other
issue is that generally we won't have
this map of the garden ok so what do we
do so one solution that's that's started
gaining currency and in parts of the
social sciences is pre-registration and
this sort of corresponds to just if you
like gating off the garden like
committing ahead of time to not making
choices as a function of the data
instead like before you even look at the
data you publicly commit to the analysis
procedures you're going to do and when
you publish a paper you you show this
public commitment that you made you know
on a on a you know website that
specializes in making these kinds of
commitments where do you say on a block
sure it's it's it's in the blockchain
this sort of it's just forcing the
analyst it's gating off the garden at
sourcing the analysts to just walk in a
straight line and if done correctly it's
safe but it's it's sort of overly
conservative because
it doesn't allow us to do data
exploration and if you think about it
it's sort of incompatible with data
reuse you know if you publish a
pre-registered study and then I read
your paper and then I want to like get
your data set and do something with it
well I've read your paper now so even if
I'm not trying to everything I do from
that point forward is somehow a function
of the data because your paper was so we
want to think about what we can do to
make it safe to walk in the garden of
forking paths'
so let me now write down a formalization
of this problem so that we can think
about it rigorously this is a particular
formalization but not the only one maybe
I'll try to mention things that are
important than things that are not but
let's just sort of go through the
formalization that I'm gonna specify but
but don't think of all of these as
essential assumptions just think about
this as a particular framework I'm
setting up so that we can see what's
possible so one of the things we'll have
in this world is what I'll call a data
universe okay these are just this is
just the space from which our individual
data set entries live in so for example
if my data set entries consist of D
boolean attributes then you know maybe
our data universe is the set of vectors
that can be written by as sort of D D
boolean variables it's not necessarily a
central but this is finite although that
will be useful for some things but not
for everything there'll be a
distribution over this data universe
okay this is ultimately the object that
we wish to learn about okay but we won't
have direct access to this distribution
instead we have a data set that just
consists of n elements sampled iid from
this distribution
okay now we're gonna talk about and this
is the part that's not strictly
necessary if it'll make things easier
we're gonna talk about answering what
I'll call statistical queries this is a
name from the machine learning
literature but you know if you haven't
heard that name before don't worry it's
a very simple object a statistical query
is just some predicate defined over the
data universe so for example it might be
like the loss function of your
classifier does it miss classify an
example or not and the answer to its
disk will query the thing we want to
estimate it's just the expected value of
this predicate when I draw a new example
from the distribution so if this is like
the 0 1 loss function for your
classifier this is the true
classification error rate of your of
your model okay and the thing that we
are going to want to try to design is a
statistical query Oracle which is just
an algorithm that's going to be
parametrized by our data set and we'll
take as input sequence of queries that
we want to ask and will spit out numbers
which are purportedly the answers to
those queries and we want to think about
adaptively chosen queries so here in
this example here's the algorithm we get
to design the algorithm is parametrized
by some data sets which is drawn iid
from this distribution but the algorithm
doesn't have any other direct access to
the distribution its access is only
through the data set okay and the
queries are going to be adaptive so our
our data analysts will ask some query
and the the statistical estimator we
design will give some answer ok the data
analyst now gets to think about that
answer and ask another query you get
some other answer ok and he'll continue
in this way asking K questions and the
point is this is happening happening
sequentially so you know like the the
choice of what question he asks that
step T can be a function of all of the
answers he's received at previous steps
ok and so now we want to design
statistical estimators that have nice
properties well what do we want as our
nice property we want that our estimator
should be able to like give correct
answers with sort of valid confidence
intervals
no matter what sequence of adaptively
chosen queries we've asked so we don't
want to assume anything about the actual
procedure we don't assume about anything
about what the data analyst is doing we
want to sort of state properties that we
can we can prove only knowing something
about the statistical estimator
okay so we'll say that we'll say that a
statistical estimator is epsilon-delta
accurate if for any set of k queries
asked by an arbitrary data analyst so
it'll be a universal quantifier over the
data analyst and no matter what
distribution the data was drawn from
with high probability with probability
one minus Delta we want that in the
worst case over all of the questions
that were asked the answers that our
statistical estimator produced had error
only Epsilon when compared to the real
answers on the distribution okay so
these are just simultaneous confidence
intervals around all K questions asked
but we want that our estimator should
have guarantees that are so universally
quantified over all possible data
analysts and all possible distributions
so our main quantity of interest it's
gonna be you know like when we when we
think about what kinds of estimators we
can design it's you know how quickly you
must the width of our confidence
intervals Epsilon scale up with the
number of questions that are asked and
how quickly do they scale down with the
size of our data set okay so just for
point of comparison in the non adaptive
case when we can just apply a huffing
bound and a Union bound our confidence
interval our simultaneous confidence
intervals have with that scale up only
with the logarithm of the number of
questions asked okay and in our sort of
example overfitting attack we saw that
the confidence in our where the
algorithm was just responding with the
exact empirical estimate of all of the
questions asked we saw that if we wanted
to endow that with valid confidence
intervals they would have to scale up
with the square root of the number of
questions asked so something that was
exponentially worse and the question is
you know like in the adaptive case do we
have to settle for something like this
or can we
you know if we're clever design
statistical estimators that do better
okay so we want to like move
this closer to this
okay so let's start with a with an easy
theorem I've dumped the harder theorem
on Adam so here's an easy theorem and
it's maybe a theorem of the sort
you know if pigs could fly then then
cats could dance because it's gonna have
a condition that is like not obvious a
priori that you can meet in an
interesting way okay but the theorem
itself is easy to prove so let's say
that we've got a statistical estimator
that has the property that has two
properties okay first no matter what
sequence of adaptively chosen queries
are actually asked to it it should be
empirically accurate okay by which I
mean if I look at the worst case overall
of the queries of the sort of error of
the answer given to that query not
measured with respect to the true
distribution which we don't know but
just measured with respect to the
empirical estimate okay so the
difference between the answer our
estimator gives and the empirical
estimate of our question on the true
data set that shouldn't be too big that
should be bounded by some some tau okay
fine so so you know we can easily make
this zero for example just by answering
with empirical estimates exactly okay
but so if it has this property but then
it also has this second property which
I'll call compressibility okay that the
transcript no matter what questions are
asked to the transcript of answers given
by the estimator can always be described
concisely there's some way to compress
its answers to be represented with only
T bits okay then I claim you've got you
know an interesting statistical
estimator and you can say that it's
epsilon-delta accurate so so with high
probability answers all of its questions
correctly up to error epsilon where the
epsilon parameter is now okay tau I mean
you can't really beat that Plus this
quantity that now scales only
logarithmically with the number of
questions asked okay this was like what
we had in the non adaptive case but also
with the square root of now not the
number of questions but the number of
bits to which your estimator was
compressible - okay so this is you know
a big improvement over square root of K
over N if you can somehow come up with
an estimator for which T is much smaller
than K oh and I said there's a I wrote
if pigs could fly because it shouldn't
be like a priori obvious that you know
you should be able to have non-trivial
estimators that set T to be
substantially smaller than K all right
because the thing we have to compress is
the the numeric answers to like K
arbitrary questions they were asked
about the data set okay but this is a
theorem and it's got a very easy proof
so well I'll do it for you now yeah I
guess the compressor
good question it´ll yeah so it'll become
yeah it maybe it'll become clear in the
discussion that follows but it should be
compressible by the analyst if you know
his random coins after you know the
answers that were given to you so so the
analysts knowing his random coins and
the sequence of answers given by the
algorithm should be able to perform the
compression so let's prove the theorem
and just so we don't have to worry about
the random coins of the analyst let's
think about a deterministic analyst but
it doesn't that's not an important
distinction so if any data analysts okay
what could be a human being it's just
some function mapping the answers he's
gotten to his questions to the next
question he's going to ask okay so it
maps every sequence of query answers to
a sequence of queries that are asked
right so the point is just for every
every sequence of K queries asked
corresponds to some particular
transcript of answers that was generated
by the statistical estimator eh okay so
like one immediate fact about
compressibility if we can always
compress these transcripts to T bits
there's only two to the T of them so
that means but actually you know even
though we assume nothing about this data
analyst
there's he can't ask that many questions
right like for every transcript of
answers of which there's only two to the
T of them he asks K questions so there's
only K times two to the T questions that
he can ever ask so let's just apply you
know once we once we know a finite
number of questions that can be asked
even though we don't know the identity
of those questions because we don't know
who the data analyst is we can still
apply a bun for any correction so we can
still apply out just a huffing bound and
a Union bound
where we're now going to union-bound not
over you know like to to the K things
but over K times 2 to the T things ok so
we get that our generalization error in
the worst case over these K times two to
the T many queries well it's at most
this something that looks like the
square root of T plus log K over N let's
think about deterministic analysts for
now but since it will hold for all
deterministic analysts we can integrate
over the randomness exactly ok so this
is just bounding the difference between
our sort of sample error and our
distributional error just with a tufting
bound and a and a Union bound well we
also assumed that our empirical accuracy
was good the distance between our
empirical error and the answer actually
provided by the mechanism was small by
assumption and so the theorem which is
just you know says our ultimate error is
the sum of these two terms that just
follows from the triangle inequality ok
so this is not a complicated theorem
there's a sort of straightforward way
you can come up with generalization
guarantees for adaptively answered
queries with the big caveat that in
order for this theorem to apply you have
to come up with some like pretty good
way to compress the answers to to
produce by these transcripts
okay so you know for most of the rest of
the talk I'm gonna think about ways in
which we might design algorithms that
compress answer that generate
compressible transcripts but let me
first reflect on the strengths of this
style of theorem and the more
complicated theorem but that Adams gonna
talk about so first like the hypotheses
of this theorem are entirely about the
statistical estimator that we get to
design okay there you know agnostic to
the details of the data analyst which we
get to universally quantify over so you
know like we don't need a map of the
garden we don't need to be able to like
draw out this garden of the forking
paths'
we can apply the bun for any correction
to what we can reason is only a bounded
number of queries even though we don't
know what they are which means that like
we don't have to like the data analyst
doesn't have to be like an algorithm
that we have to think about it could be
a human being also since like we're
universally quantifying over data
analysts you know other than sort of
requiring that the data analysts
interact with the data only through our
interface we don't have to constrain him
at all okay so he is promised you know
like an interface for which he can ask
questions and we're promising that the
answer is that he gets are always pretty
accurate so long as he can interact in
that method like we don't have to
constrain what he's doing so in
comparison to pre-registration he's got
sort of you know full full rein to do
whatever he likes okay and so the the
main question that comes out once you've
seen this theorem is are there
non-trivial estimators that actually
like satisfy the conditions of the
theorem okay the answer is yes let me
let me sort of I'm gonna go through
three of them now that will that will
each have sort of different kinds of
guarantees the first will be a little
bit heuristic the second will have
worst-case guarantees but only for a
particular kind of use case and then the
third will be able to answer arbitrary
statistical queries
okay but but first let's maybe think
about like a general framework that we
can think about for designing
compressible estimators okay so suppose
for a moment that whenever we get a
question whenever the statistical
estimator gets a question that's this
little query it comes also with a guess
GI for what the answer to that question
is going to be who knows where these
guesses are coming from but suppose
questions are paired with guesses well
in that case when we get a query of this
sorts there's two ways we can answer
right ku remember we have to be tau
accurate our errors allowed to be only
at most tau with respect to the
empirical answer so it could be that the
guess is also is already empirically
accurate the difference between the
guests and the like sample error is
already less than tau in which case we
don't really have to answer with a
number we can just say yep right because
the data analyst once he learns yep
knows that he actually already has a
number that tells him up to error tau
what the answer is okay
of course you know like the guest is
probably won't always be right so when
they're wrong when the error is larger
than tau we say nope and then we
actually provide a number we tell him an
empirical answer that has error you know
tau so suppose we had the additional
guarantee that not only do these
questions come with guesses but that the
guesses are often correct meaning that
only W of these guesses are wrong
there's sort of an obvious way to
compress things okay so it's one way to
encode this transcript is to you know if
I know that it's only the guesses were
only wrong a small number of times I'm
only going to tell you about those days
in which the guesses were wrong and you
can then figure out that on all of the
other day is the answer was yep okay so
it's a one simple you know way to like
encode this transcript it is to just
write down a bunch of tuples okay each
tuple will contain the index of a
question whose guess was wrong and then
it'll also contain since we have to
provide an empirically
for those questions a numerical answer
to that question but since we only need
to have empirical accuracy tau I only
need to write down the numerical answer
to the like log 1 over tau bits of
precision ok so you know we can compress
such transcripts to roughly you know W
plus log K plus log 1 over tau bits of
precision because well we're writing
down W tuples there's only W entries in
this list if the guesses were wrong only
W times and then in every tuple we had
to write down an index of a query that's
a number between 1 and K so that takes
log K bits and we had to write down also
a numeric value to answer but only to
log 1 over tau bits of precision so
immediately you get just by sort of
plugging this in that if somehow we
could if somehow our questions were
paired with guesses and we knew that
only W of them were ever going to be
wrong then we would get you know
confidence interval widths that sort of
scale like this they scale with what
looks like the confidence interval with
just when we take a sort of Union bound
a bonferroni correction over k non
adaptively chosen queries then but but
then within the square root to W here
okay so our error scales not with the
number of questions that were asked but
with the number of questions whose
answers were wrong
zip so the point is to come up with
compressible estimators which you know
who knows if we can do it suffice is to
come up with a way of coming up with
good guesses for the questions we ask
okay also not clear if we can do that
yeah oh you know maybe you could replace
it with a square root log or something
when balancing the two terms you know
like Tao is going to be some you know
like one over poly n term like when you
opt it like ultimately you're gonna
optimize for tau and just it's basically
some sort of palm grove worse case
that's right any encoding that the data
analyst could do that's right so so that
reduces our problem to you know coming
up with a way to augment queries with
good guesses for their answers okay and
it should be you should be able to come
up with these guesses with only
information that the data analyst has
but of course it's not actually
necessary that the data analyst comes up
with guesses himself you know the this
all this all works if it's the
statistical estimator coming up with the
guesses so long as the statistical
estimator is doing so only from
information that's available to the data
analyst
so I want to go through three ways of
coming up with guesses okay the first is
gonna have sort of only sort of a
heuristic guarantee for how many guesses
are wrong and we'll go through a couple
of other ways okay but here's a way that
like might work well in practice it has
called the reusable holdout from a paper
that we had with Cynthia and Vitaly and
Moritz and Tony potosí and OMA Rheingold
a few years ago okay so it's actually a
very simple idea we're just gonna take
our data set s and we're gonna split it
in half say okay into a dirty set and a
clean set okay and we're gonna give the
clean set to our sort of statistical
estimator we're going to try to get
transcripts that are compressible with
respect to the clean set so we'll get
sort of statistical validity guarantees
with respect to the clean set and we're
just going to use the dirty set to come
up with our guesses okay so for every
query that's asked the guests for the
answer to that query is just the
empirical answer of that query on the
dirty set and then the thing that gets
submitted to the statistical estimator
which is parametrized by the clean set
is just the query asked together with
our guess just the empirical answer to
that query on the dirty set and to make
sure that you know no more than W
guesses are wrong since we're not going
to have really formal guarantees about
how often this process is going to come
up with a wrong guess we're just gonna
like cut things off we're gonna halt
if sufficiently many guesses are wrong
if more than W guesses are wrong to the
sort of error tolerance that they will
be allowed to be wrong with that are our
compressibility theorem has
okay so this is an algorithm that takes
sort of a parameter W so I've described
it as if the analyst is doing it but of
course that's not necessary it could be
that the statistical estimator has you
know has the whole data set
splits it into these two things and like
so whenever I whenever I'm talking about
the analyst computing a guess I think
about that as the statistical estimator
really coming up with the guess I've
written it as if the analyst does it
just to sort of emphasize that it you
know it's very important that the
guesses use only information that's
available to the analyst but the guess
the guessing process can be like
automated by the API that we design so
we just halt if more than W guesses were
wrong okay so the guarantees but this
have that this process has are a little
bit here a stick event as a theorem but
what the theorem says is that so long as
this procedure continues to be able to
answer questions you have the guarantee
that none of the answers to your
questions are going to buy more than you
know the square root of W log K over N
so there will be sort of much more
accurate than sort of the answers you
could get from like a naive empirical
sample estimator so long as you chose W
to be something pretty small but like
the guarantee that we don't have is that
this thing will answer all of your
questions right because this thing is
just going to have like a sharp cutoff
when you when you answer W questions
wrong it's gonna stop okay so so when it
stops this sort of a heuristic guarantee
the point is that so first one
observation you know if you remember
from the very beginning this sort of
simple like a majority attack
well this procedure will entirely you
know break that attack in the sense that
in that attack there was really only one
adaptive step we asked for the
correlation of each feature with the
label which by just a standard you know
like bonferroni correction
action will tend to agree on the the
dirty set and the clean set because
there was no ad apptivity there and we
really sort of overfits up in the last
query when we then from this information
constructed a model so there there was
sort of you know we were like the
possibility for one overfitting query
and this thing will we'll stop that so
long as W is bigger than one okay so it
fixes that attack yeah in this procedure
that you're running how does the
algorithm answer yes without actually
acquiring a bit because using the
algorithm doesn't answer anything but
that's effectively sequential way right
so you just need that like after the
fact basically it's compressible because
you just need to count the number of
transcripts that could be generated so
the point is if if most of the answers
are yep I don't you know I can more
concisely describe the transcript to you
than telling you you think I said yep on
day one that's right I just like
ultimately oh that's right ultimately
all I need is that there can't be that
many different transcripts
okay and and then sort of more generally
the kind of thing this promises is that
you know this will allow you to answer
questions for a long time since we only
depend logarithmically on K with
accuracy guarantees so long as you're
doing something sensible basically so
long as you haven't gotten lost in this
garden of the forking paths' you have
access to it and it's going to catch and
correct you know up to W instances of
overfitting and stop after W but if
you're doing something that is actually
not overfitting then you can keep using
this so now let me talk about the latter
mechanism which is something that Darin
Blum and Moritz developed a couple of
years ago this is going to be a
mechanism that has formal guarantees so
there's no heuristic aspect of that but
it will be limited to this ative
answering up words it's limited to
maintaining a leaderboard in a machine
learning competition so it's not a
general-purpose mechanism okay so the
idea here is to sort of do something
like you know what the image net folks
might have liked to provide the
functionality they wanted but prevent
the kind of cheating that Baidu did
people are gonna submit machine learning
models to this leaderboard and what we
want to be able to sort of consistently
answer with is the accuracy of the best
model that's been submitted so far okay
so here's how you can design a
compressible version of that in this
guessing framework you know initially
prac of what's the best error so far
initially you know 100 percent okay and
now you know sequentially people will
submit classifiers okay they'll say
here's my machine learning model I've
you know is it the best model so far and
if so what's that so what's its error
okay so that corresponds to a query that
if you noticed is not a statistical
query but that's okay right so if I've
just submitted the model F then the
query I'm really interested in asking is
what is the sort of loss of the best
model that's been submitted so far
maybe it's the model submitted today but
maybe it's something submitted
previously and the guests that we're
gonna come up with is just that the
current model hasn't substantially
improved okay that the current model is
within Tao of the error of the of the
sort of best model yesterday so our
guest is always going to be whatever the
best error is so far okay and then we'll
you know compute the answer by just
submitting to our compressible estimator
the query and the guess okay and you
know if the model we just submitted had
error that did not improve by tau over
the best previous thing will just say
yep your guess was right the best thing
is within tau of whatever it was
yesterday but if the guess was wrong by
more than tau our estimator you know
provides a numerical answer saying what
the current best error is and we'll
update our guest the best error now when
we guess tomorrow will be whatever the
error of today's model was
okay so now we can really so first you
know like okay this is maintaining a
leaderboard it's not answering arbitrary
statistical queries but it will have a
guarantee that like we can really
there's nothing heuristic about this we
can really prove that the guests will be
wrong only a you know bounded number of
times because the error of a classifier
is like a number between zero and one
and every time a guess was wrong it
meant that the current model improved by
tau over the last one so we've sort of
lowered that error by tau and you can't
lower a number between 0 and 1 by tau
more than 1 over tau many times so the
number of errors the sort of the number
of times the guess was wrong by more
than tau is bounded by 1 over tau okay
and so we can just apply the sort of
compressibility theorem the total error
is just tau plus the square root of 1
over tau log K over N now tau is
something we as the designer get to pick
so we just picked out to optimize this
error and we get a pretty good bound
something that is that goes to zero at a
rate of log K over N to the one-third
okay so it's answering a limited class
of queries these leaderboard queries but
now our error is sort of looking like
what you would get in the non adaptive
case okay that the exponents not quite
right it's not one half it's one third
now but the error is growing only you
know like logarithmically and the number
of questions asked just not polynomial
maybe Moritz knows the answer to that in
like the same do you want a sample size
collect little bit in this ballon I mean
it would be bad all right but I could do
fly drastically it's pretty reasonable
okay
twiddle so I don't have to answer
questions like that exactly it's don't
ask ok and now let me walk through a
method that will allow you to answer
arbitrary sequences of statistical
queries ok so again let's imagine that
our data universe is consists of these
sort of D binary attributes for this
that's actually sort of important that
your data universe has sort of finite
dimensionality and we're gonna take
advantage of that
so just in describing how this is going
to work there's one important fact that
I want you to remember that is no matter
what sequence of K statistical queries
the analyst ended up asking like ex post
ex post there will always have been some
data set that I could have constructed
of size only log K over tau squared that
actually encodes all of the answers with
empirical error only tau with respect to
my real data set and that's sort of for
a simple reason like ex post after the K
questions have been asked well you know
now I can think about just taking a
fresh sample of data from the
distribution and with respect to this
new sample the questions are now
non-adaptive so I just apply a huffing
bound on the bun for any correction and
to get error tau across all of those
questions I need this many samples ok so
I don't know what this data set looks
like but I know that ex post there will
have been a pretty small data set but
encoded the answers to all of these
queries importantly since there's only
two to the D like data elements here if
I wanted to enumerate all such small
data sets well I could in principle do
that there's only two to the D the
number of universe elements times log K
over tau squared
number of distinct ones I might need
small datasets so now here is the method
for coming up with guesses initially I'm
going to just write down the set of all
small data sets there's a lot of them
but I can in principle write them down
if I use enough twiddles so now okay
what query comes in what's what's my
gifts I'm gonna do a pretty natural
thing my guess is going to be computed
as follows I'll just evaluate the query
on all of the data sets and mice in my
big collection of small data sets see
that'll give me a bunch of different
numbers and my guess that's to what the
answer is going to be for your query is
the median of those numbers okay then
that was how I came up with a guess I'll
just submit the query on the guest to my
estimator and if the guess was correct
yeah corrected upto error tau that's
great well I won't make any change at
all to my set of consistent small data
sets but if the guest was wrong right
meaning I actually had to get some
numeric value to answer that had error
more than tau with respect to my guess
then I will just sort of update my set
of consistent data sets to be consistent
with this new answer meaning I will
remove all of the data sets in this set
that with respect to my guests had error
less than tau a rather had ever greater
than tau or it's right now I'll remove
all the ones that today are less than
tau because I learned that the real
answer was further away than tau from my
guess and so I know that like there's
this one small data set that is going to
ultimately encode all of the answers
correctly but it's not one of the ones I
removed
okay well now we can just think about
how often my guesses will be wrong
we know that initially my set was it was
pretty big but not that big it was two
to the D times log K over tau squared
and along the way I'm removing you know
data sets that turned out to be
inconsistent with my guesses but since I
took the set of all small data sets to
begin with and I know that ex-post one
of them will be consistent I know that
I'm never gonna throw away everything no
matter how long I run this thing for
they'll always be at least one data set
and my consistent set and here's the
important thing because we were guessing
the median every time the median was
wrong by more than tau we cut the size
of our consistent set in half right
because if the median was wrong by more
than tau then half of them had to be
wrong by more than tau okay so we
started with sort of a set of size 2 to
the D log K it never goes below size 1
and every time we make a mistake and
guess it gets cut in half so like
definitely no matter what happens the
number of times our guest is mistaken is
bounded by the log of this so just D log
K over tau squared okay we can apply our
theorem our total error is well the
empirical error tau plus what we get by
applying a bun for any correction to you
know
exponential in this many hypotheses
there's this parameter tau which again
we get to set so we just set it to
minimize this quantity and you get that
you get a sort of a bound that is sort
of making getting error that scales well
now only with log K again not polynomial
8 with K we now have a function of the
dimension here which we didn't have
before and the exponents not the right
one it's not 1/2 it's 1/4 but we can
answer arbitrary sequences of
statistical queries and you know if you
think about the number of questions we
can answer before we start getting
trivial confidence intervals it's again
something that's exponential in n rather
than
only linear in in so almost done I mean
I just sort of transition to what Adams
going to talk about let's just sort of
think about some takeaways of what we've
learned here so by thinking just about
this simple compressibility kind of
argument we can already get error that's
scaling only poly logarithmically with K
rather than polynomial e with K which
was sort of what we had to do if we
didn't think hard about how to design
these statistical estimators but our
bounds are you know could be better you
know like the bounds we were getting
didn't have the right exponent and
certainly for this last estimator I
showed you it wasn't computationally
efficient I had to like enumerate some
vast number of data sets and maybe this
sort of moral takeaway was that or one
one sort of takeaway is that like so
long as the number of questions asked
just sort of bigger than the effective
dimension of the data or like the actual
dimension of the data we can come up
with ways to start guessing the answers
really well which is what gives us these
compressibility arguments but given what
I've told you so far we don't have any
sort of theorems that provably improve
over like the naive estimator when the
number of or when the size of the data
set is actually smaller than the
dimension so these are all sort of
problems and we don't yet know how to
mitigate all of them but we know how to
mitigate some of them and this is gonna
be sort of Adams gonna show us how to
get part of the way there okay so to do
that we're gonna have to move beyond
description lengths okay so two sort of
more information theoretic kinds of
arguments but we want that whatever
thing we're we're sort of measuring
should have some of the nice properties
that we got to use with our description
length arguments again particular it
should be something that's robust to
post-processing because you know the
data analyst is going to get to
interpret and think about the answers
our estimator gives in arbitrary ways
and and because it's this inherently
sequential thing it should be something
that composed as well so if you haven't
heard of it there's there's this nice
thing that that Cynthia and and Frank
McKee and Kobe Newsome and Adam came up
with a while ago called differential
privacy and this is a stability
constraint on an algorithm okay so it's
a constraint on a randomized algorithm
that takes as input datasets which are
just collections of Records flip some
coins and then has some output
distribution and differential privacy's
accessibility constraint it says if I
change the input by a little bit by
changing one record arbitrarily but only
one record the output distribution
shouldn't change by too much a little
more formally if I've got some algorithm
mapping datasets to some arbitrary
output space we can say that it's alpha
beta differentially private if for all
pairs of data sets that are neighboring
that differ in just one element and for
all outcomes outcome events II when I
look at the probability of that outcome
when I run the algorithm on s and when I
run the algorithm on the neighboring
data set s prime those probabilities
should be close close in a
multiplicative sense by an e to the
Alpha factor and in an additive sense by
this additive term beta the crucial
property of this is that there's no
metric on the outcome space it's not a
Lipschitz condition with respect to some
metric on the outcome space it's a
stability condition on the distribution
on outputs so we don't care what the
output space is and this is going to be
what makes it robust to post-processing
okay so some useful facts you know
robustness to post-processing if you
show me an algorithm that's alpha beta
differentially private then I can take
some arbitrary function that just looks
at the output of this algorithm and maps
it to something else and when I compose
these two things I sort of run your
algorithm and then I map its output to
something else in an arbitrary way this
sort of composition is also
differentially private with the same
parameters
the important thing is we don't need to
understand anything about this function
f so it could be a precisely specified
algorithm or it could be a human data
analyst okay this is the property that
we need in order to be able to like
universally quantify overall data
analysts okay another nice property is
that it you know if you if you have a
few differentially private computations
and you run them sequentially even if
you choose the identity if these
computations adaptively the privacy
guarantee degrades in a well-behaved way
okay
so if I have an arbitrary data analyst
and then in a sequence of K rounds I let
the data analyst choose some arbitrary
computation and it's got to be a
differentially private computation with
parameter alpha in some arbitrary way as
a function of the outputs of the
previous computations and then output
the entire transcript this whole
transcript this was a sometimes called
the advanced composition theorem by
Cynthia and and guy Roth Blum and silver
Dunn says that you know with the
universal quantifiers we want you know
no matter who the data analyst is the
composition of these things will also be
differentially private where the
differential privacy parameter degrades
only with the square root of the number
of rounds of competition okay the fact
that it's degrading only with the square
root and not linearly it's going to be
the source of some of the improvements
that Adam is going to be able to tell us
about so these are two important
properties because they mean that we can
think of differential privacy as a
language for stable algorithm design
right we can we don't have to prove
differential privacy from scratch for
every new complicated algorithm which if
we designed complicated algorithms would
be really hard instead we can sort of
prove differential privacy for simple
you know modules and then glue them
together in arbitrary ways to design
complicated algorithms which will be
useful if we want to get good
statistical estimators and then just
sort of modularly reason about the
privacy properties by thinking about
post-processing and composition
the simplest primitives by the way are
extremely simple okay so suppose I have
a statistical query and I want to answer
it such that it's you know pretty
accurate with respect to the sample well
it turns out one thing I can do is just
compute the answer to that query and
then perturb it with Gaussian noise and
the noise doesn't have to be very big
right for a statistical query which is
just asking what is the average value of
some predicate over a data set of size n
sort of the standard deviation of the
noise only has to scale with 1 over N
times the privacy parameter that I want
ok so this will be sort of a small
perturbation if n is big and like
therefore the if I measure my error with
respect to the empirical answer it's
gonna be pretty small because I've just
got the empirical answer plus some noise
so if the magnitude of the noise is
small all my empirical errors and the
reason we care about small empirical
error is because we're gonna have a very
similar transfer theorem to the sort I
showed you about with description length
bounds but for differential privacy okay
so I'll leave you with this then we'll
have a break and then Adam will tell us
more about this but we've got the
following theorem so suppose we've got a
statistical estimator that again
satisfies two properties the first is
that the algorithm is differentially
private okay this is what's just this is
what's replacing the sort of
compressibility hypothesis for easy
theorem and the second is that the
algorithm is simultaneously empirically
accurate ok the answer is it gives to
statistical queries are with high
probability accurate in sample meaning
like the numeric value dancers it gets
are close to the empirical answers to
those questions on the actual data set
you've got the transfer theorem says if
you can design an estimator that has
these two properties simultaneously then
you're automatically accurate
out-of-sample okay so it's reducing this
problem again just as the sort of
description length theorem did it's
reducing this problem to a problem of
algorithm design making no reference to
the sort of district
we want to be accurate with respect to
but just with respect to sort of
in-sample things and if that we've got a
break here are the the papers I talked
about and if you want to read about some
of this stuff in a little more detail
Adam and I taught a course this last
year and we've got lecture notes on this
easy to remember website thank you we
have a coffee break